hey thoughty2 here have you ever seen a
flying bear no that's because they don't
exist but fast forward a hundred years
I'm flying bears could be freaking
everywhere
okay maybe not flying bears but
something equally as amazing and
terrifying is happening across the
entire animal kingdom creatures far and
wide are evolving faster than ever
before
and the ways in which they're evolving
is unlike anything we've ever seen
through our vast studies into evolution
we've noticed and it takes roughly 1
million years to notice a significant
change in an animal's characteristics a
major leap in its evolutionary life as
we all know zoologists bio scientists
and other experts have been constantly
monitoring animals all over the world
for hundreds of years however in the
past 50 years a huge change in how
animals evolved has been observed
instead of a million years some animals
have made huge evolutionary jumps in
just a few decades and in some cases as
little as 20 years times in 1989 the
international community after but on the
sale of ivory worldwide in an attempt to
stop the poaching of elephants for that
extremely valuable ivory tusks elephant
poaching dropped significantly in the
years that followed and elephant numbers
in the wild started to rise again but
despite its illegality the demand for
ivory never went away
especially in China where it's highly
coveted the two tusks from a single
elephant can sell for up to $400,000 on
the black market and so in this highly
lucrative market criminal gangs have met
the ever-present demand for the illegal
collectors item
poaching levels have risen once again
and sadly today around 35,000 elephants
are slaughtered every year for their
ivory that's over five percent of the
global elephant population in fact the
number of elephants coached every year
is now
far greater done before the ban in 1989
but the elephants are fighting back yet
they don't even know how every year more
and more elephants are born without any
tusks at all because today an elephant
is more likely to survive and reproduce
if it has no valuable tusks for poachers
to kill it over even if this means it
can't defend itself against rival
elephants in Gambia the amount of
tourists female elephants rose from 10%
to 40% in just 20 years
that's evolution happening right before
our eyes in an astonishingly short
twenty year period and all because of
the actions of a few unsavory humans in
some areas of South Africa 98% female
elephants have no ivory now most humans
like living in cities goodness knows why
all the research shows that were
considerably less happy and less safe in
cities but nonetheless we have a natural
desire to swarm around giant metal hubs
of weird modern art and 24-hour fast
food restaurants and our cities are
growing at a rate faster than ever
before
currently 54 percent of the global
population lives in an urban centre by
2050 it's estimated to rise to 70% this
will of course mean a far greater
percentage of the earth natural habitats
will be destroyed so we can build more
mix Kentucky Fried Subway's with vast
spluttering zuv vegan cafes to support
the growing urban population this of
course is bad news for avocados avocado
abuse is already rising at a phenomenal
rate but it's even worse news
for the animal kingdom or maybe it isn't
destruction of natural habitats is of
course devastating to the species that
once called that place home but like the
great African elephant animals far and
wide are supercharging there ever
to adapt to life inside the city
humans are forcing them to because it's
either adapt to the urban environment or
become extinct
coyotes are traditionally found in habit
in the great grasslands of Middle
America but in the past few decades they
have spread across the whole country and
now inhabit every major city across
America where they have found themselves
our unique home they are highly
threatened in their natural habitat the
US government kills 400,000 creatives
every year under the guise of wildlife
services they call it population
management so heavily persecuted coyotes
have been forced to masterfully adapt to
the urban lifestyle they will eat quite
literally anything from litter to bits
of clothing found lying around amazingly
after being monitored extensively on
CCTV it was observed that coyotes
monitor traffic patterns and vehicle
speeds in order to cross roads safely in
Chicago alone there are an estimated
2,000 coyotes living successfully within
the urban sprawl urban birds are also
adapting their street smarts scientists
at a problem-solving test for different
species of birds living in cities and
then they carried out the same test on
rural birds the city slickers were found
to be significantly smarter than their
rural counterparts and were able to
solve the problems far quicker urban
birds have learned to steal sugar
packets from tables outside restaurants
and cafes and they even steal food from
people's plate when they're not looking
now these may not be examples of true
evolution where a physical mutation
becomes the new norm but they do
represent huge changes in the way
animals behave due to human intervention
but then again this is exactly how
evolution starts it won't be long before
urban dwelling animals do evolve
physically to meet the new demands and
challenges that a city lifestyle
presents them with and some already have
just look at what humans have done with
their best friend the dog humans created
dogs 15,000 years ago though were no
dogs we formed an unlikely relationship
with great wolves and over the next few
thousand years as our relationship with
wolves evolved so did they these fierce
predators at the top of their respective
food chain became more docile their
bodies shrunk and so did their teeth and
paws their ears went all floppy so most
humans would have to scratch behind them
more often there are now hundreds of
breeds of dogs around the world with
vastly different characteristics and
personalities yet they are all able to
reproduce with one another because they
all came from the same species
now if human intervention is able to
create an entirely new species of animal
within such a tiny period of time for
15,000 years and the possibilities are
endless for how other animals can and
will change over the next 1,000 years
and beyond the common theme here is that
we aren't trying to change animals we
didn't intend to alter the wolf so
radically but through rapid evolution
they have adapted themselves to fit
around us humans the exact same process
is now happening on an unimaginably
large scale worldwide due to
urbanization the effects of human driven
evolution in animals is not just a
theory just like with the African
elephants and their ivory the effects
have been observed over countless
species of animals in recent decades
songbirds have changed their tune so
that their acoustics are not lost within
the constant background noise of the
city below spiders and cities are
getting far bigger than their rural
cousins calm down I'm not going to show
an image insects rats and mice are
becoming immune to insecticides and rat
poisons and bad news for those who are
screamish about books because bedbugs
are fast becoming highly resistant
to all the harsh chemicals that we've
been throwing at them to try and
exterminate them in the past few decades
bed books have become 250 times more
resistant to pesticides and have
developed significantly harder shells
even weeds are getting in on the action
they've developed the resistance to weed
killers meaning we're now going to have
to rename all weed killers to weed nuts
killers flowers that are often picked by
romantic Park dwelling couples are
becoming shorter and shorter every year
so that they can hide amongst the other
plants and are therefore less likely to
get spotted and picked from the ground
and on a far larger scale pretty much
all species of animals across the planet
have changed their fertility cycle due
to global warming
many species now breed earlier on in the
year and they used it to account for the
messed up seasons brought on by global
warming a number of the biggest problems
that our urban lifestyles are causing
animals is chemical pollution we use a
lot of packaging and buy a lot of shiny
new technology all of this requires the
use of chemicals to produce it and a lot
of these harmful chemicals will
inevitably find their way into our
rivers and some fish are unable to adapt
to this pollution and so are wiped out
other species however have rapidly
evolved to become entirely resistant to
toxins within the water Atlantic
killifish found in the Passaic River and
Newark Bay in New Jersey are now able to
tolerate toxicity levels 8,000 times
higher than over fish at rates that
they've been forced to develop due to a
nearby chemical factory linking it's
toxic leftovers into the rivers they can
literally swim around and horrific lis
toxic water all day long without any ill
effects whatsoever the amazing thing is
that secluded populations of these
killer fish develop this anti toxic
adaptation at the exact same time with
ever coming into contact with one
another humans may not be the most
considerate of species for a long time
we have disregarded the needs of our
animal cousins in exchange for rapid
industrialization and urbanization so
it's rather endearing to know that
nature will mold itself to fit around
our foibles and thankfully nature is
powerful and smart enough to be able to
change so rapidly to a new or hospitable
environment or if it wasn't many of the
incredible creatures that we've come to
care about would probably be extinct
today thanks for watching if for some
reason you actually enjoy my videos then
click here to support me on patreon
supporting me helps me to make better
videos and you can get some pretty cool
rewards as well click here to check out
another video and if you haven't already
don't forget to subscribe for new videos
every week